[Music]
all right so we saw two of them this
week we couldn't see three because they
were having a big fourth of July for the
July thing here that it was just a crowd
itself by the movie
because there's like a lake and a park
right over there and they always have
this mutual aid fourth of July
yeah and the cops are over here and it's
just like definitely full authority but
just like a rock concert yeah so we'll
be able to see two and then next week
we'll probably be able to see two
because she had reset don't worry about
it okay I'll see you consider three
that's working right yeah
first one we're gonna do is going to do
was a spider-man what's going partner my
barber fiery Marvel movie
I've already kind of prejudiced against
more of Marvel
really like Marvel recently
I seemed to like DC but I don't really
seem to like Marvell
but you know I saw the old spider-man so
you know Toby told me wired the first
couple months were really good I grew up
watching the cartoon you know spider-man
spider-man you know you know the comic
books of the 70s so I know the character
real well
Jenny liked the movie you liked him
opening he was pretty good actually I'm
gonna say and this is probably a hot
take but I think I liked it a little bit
better than endgame just because endgame
was like such a bummer and it was like
you know sad and
kind of like heavy [ __ ] going on this
one much more like not a straight comedy
I don't think but it had like a lot of
comedy elements in it it was almost kind
of like European vacation like the
National Lampoon movie but with
superheroes and I actually kind of liked
that I like the like the lighter tone
you know coming after like a
and game being so heavy and like so many
deaths
kind of [ __ ] so you know I kind of
appreciated that it almost seemed like
they were kind of feeling more for a
like Shazam type of
in a way they were yeah so I appreciated
that it was kind of cute funny like you
know the I particularly liked the
villain whose Playboy
Jake Gyllenhaal
Mysterio I thought that was really kind
of not gonna spoil my wait out all that
went down but that's like a big you
but honestly I think he was probably the
best part about it and obviously said
well Jackson yes
every piece like always like students
like when ru shows up but he said
there's quite a bit you'd like he seems
like super cranky and so he's like much
funnier do you recommend a movie um if
you okay like I like I said if you like
I and I'm gonna say right now I didn't
see spider-man homecoming the one before
this those
so I don't know how similar it is I
don't know if it's funny as well um if
you like Shazam if you wanted to see
something that was marble that was not
so heavy that's particularly after and
games and probably you will like this
like I said it's it's very much like a
high school like um like a high school
comedy like European vacation we mix
with high school kids with super here so
if that sounds like something that you
would like I didn't like I didn't love
it but I enjoyed it well in the time
okay I think the strong points the movie
was Mysterio yeah I think that was a
really good character I would like to
say look and I like what they did with
him yeah I liked that and of course Sam
Jackson almost tries to save this movie
tries to save this movie but for me I
just I can't recommend
I like the old spider-man a lot better
okay I'm gonna get right down to it if
you ask me this this actor he could he
could probably do a really good
spider-man but the way the materials
were written the way it's directed and
everything I'm not getting spider-man
I'm getting spider boy he's still spider
boy at this stage and it doesn't come
off as good as his Shazam played that
angle when he grows up become spider-man
and then maybe I might like this
character but I just didn't like the
humor
betta as hell he's crying there in parts
of it it's
it's just didn't like it and didn't have
the hallmarks of this franchise I mean
the way they changed up MJ and
everything and I thought Kristen Dunst
really was cast a lot better you know
that's you know the kind of heat you
know
going all way back to the comment books
you know MJ was kind of like a trophy
girlfriend you know she was just this
good-looking redhead that you know
she's got a yuppie in a way but you know
that's just the way that story went I
just didn't like they changed it up too
much
oh you know MJ's kind of just like the
average girl you know dressing down and
with the flannel plant a lot and there's
nothing special about her really it was
she just be lost out the crowd and that
is I think maybe in the modern era
they're gonna try to sell that angle
like yeah you know anybody's a superhero
anybody's gonna be the girlfriend of
superhero so just you know put any old
book person up there
I'm just not into it man I'm just not
into it and like the way they got Peter
Parker the way he's acted in this movie
can't be a hero around me I don't know I
just it doesn't make sense I mean he did
go to space and Samuel Jackson pointed
this out Nick Fury pointed out you went
to space what are you crying for he did
all this other stuff that was kind of
brave why is he such a [ __ ]
well there was like a reason for that
but I can't really give it away with
that just it doesn't make me that's
willing what like major quits when
they're trying to use reason with me
it's doesn't work these are mythological
tales and spider-man is a certain way
you know and it's just not shown that
way in this movie you know he's he's a
bully and I don't want to see that I
want to see spider-man I want to see
spider boy
such didn't like it I like Shazam though
because that character is a boy that
turned into a damn
superhero and
he was more heroic than spider-man if
you ask me I'm I don't talk about do I
recommend the movie No
okay second one we're gonna do is
midsummer midsummer all right this one
is basically if you saw The Wicker Man
the original women man it's like not
that very much like the original Wicker
Man it also the tone kind of reminded me
what was that movie that you saw you
like for a while by the satanic cult
where they had that special girl and the
predator yeah the same director okay the
same directives that there's a second
she I can't recognize it I might be done
but I'm not that done it reminded me a
lot of area okay it reminded me a lot of
that one except I like this one a lot
better I didn't like hereditary I love
to hereditary but I was looking forward
to the PSA we have different tastes and
[ __ ] you know that's fine
you know I mean we're never gonna agree
all the way this one I liked a lot
better than hereditary it also kind of
reminded me a little bit of superior the
nuisance period I was thinking that as
well yeah but I thought I thought this
is a much stronger movie than hereditary
if you've never seen Wickerman you might
want to see this one they're not action
movies it's not a horror movie like you
would expect it to be there's suspense
in it it's just weird it's about some
people that get invited to sweet to go
see this [ __ ] festival but then when
you get there the pom pom yeah in a
comment but then you get there you find
out it's a damn kind of like a Norse
cult it's a bunch of like paganism and
folk folk and religious they kind of
show kind of cool aspects of that but
then as it gets it gets weirder and
weirder
I liked it
I wasn't sure whether or not they were
demonizing old folk religions or not I
don't think they necessarily were I
think it took a pretty even-handed
I mean Simone to it all we really know
really about someone is someone really
old but where that just comes from the
almonds and
they talked a lot about animal
sacrificed and
occasionally human sacrifice but they
did what they weren't really described
as being frightening
or weird ordering or having really being
that deep was just they were just
described like other folk group well
without this one and one of the things
that I thought was really cool about
this is that the people I'm not gonna
say they don't seem threatening but they
don't seem overtly threatening it's kind
of like The Wicker ran in that way
whereas it's like you know that like
some sinister [ __ ] is going on but it's
still not like I said it's not coming
across they're just kind of like what
this is I mean you know if you're just
like how we do stuff and it's like but
you're seeing it from the point of view
of the protagonists who don't have any
idea what's going on due to that it
seems super bizarro and super sinister
yeah but people there it doesn't see and
it's not an ancient cult it's only 90
years old
and they're using Oracle's and stuff and
they're I recommend the movie I mean I
can't spoil anything because the the
mean draw of this movie is a is the girl
that played from fight with my family
and a Florence
yeah she's awesome in this and she's
really good as cute as a bug and [ __ ]
goes down it's a good movie yeah I'm an
estate agent don't be expectant and
adding something like child's play it's
not like I don't know this is like this
is an atmospheric like creepy weird and
I like to because said because it's set
in Sweden and it's set in mid-summer
and pretty much the entire thing to
explain
in the daytime because you know there's
no night really at that time of year you
know above the Arctic Circle I'm going
to say like I said it's long it's about
two and a half hours and there's a lot
of you know just just really creepy kind
of like I said if you like to read eteri
this is re Esther's second movie so I
was really like I love to look at her
edit area so this is
also I'm gonna recommend it if you like
the original wicker man if you liked the
witch which was a 24 also if you liked
the Thomas Tryon novel harvest home this
will be right up your alley because very
very similar kind of toned about if you
like bands like death and to the current
93
this is detective Rome and although it's
like well like I said it's Santa moving
it builds up a lot of character builds
up a lot setting it's like wicked it
just like leaves you with this really
unsettling news you know something bad
is gonna happen but you just you don't
know what and so it just cut out how or
exactly right and it's like so the whole
time like I was sitting there watching
the movie and like the whole time I just
have my little thing clamped on the book
and feel like that because you just
knows the bad shits gonna happen you
know it's not like super violent there
are some like really like if you're
squeamish about gore
there's a couple scenes in this this
will prompt it will probably bother you
if you should but yeah it's just the
whole thing is just like this really
really creepy just paid in in the the
audience was pretty silent through a lot
of it they were side and then they
walked out I'm not sure how many have
understood it yeah I'm like well if
there was a meaning to it and Jenny had
that kind of explained the very ant to
me because I left a couple times ago the
restroom and you measures a couple like
keep yeah and then there's stuff and
that there's stuff in the very beginning
of it that happens that I thought was
kind of boring it's a little bit of a
slow starter that first 10 minutes
but they're shown to you for a reason it
relates to the very few flashes of the
movie and like I said this and I was
actually gonna say this I'm glad that
you mentioned it this does in town this
disc does come off very much like these
Suspiria remake from last year which was
I mean other than hereditary that knows
my second favorite or maybe last year
that came out but if so she's dug that
it's also very similar kind of vibe to
that if you like that kind of slow burn
a type of thing that just kind of
ratchets up and it just gets creepier
and creepier than I think you'll really
dig this it's good foot
[Music]